كم مره راويه كم مره كم مره نسيت اين وضعت
هاتفك في المنزل او وين مفتاح سيارتك او
ان كنت قد اغلقت الباب ام لا او حتى كنت
تتحدث في موضوع وفجاه نسيت اسماء الاشخاص
من حولك حتى القرار منهم
عاديه تحدث لدى الكثيرين في الحياه
اليوميه لكن الواضح مشاهدينا انا ظاهره في
ازدياد والسؤال هل يعد هذا النوع او هذا
النسيان هو نوع من انواع الزهايمر اطباء
دماغ واعصاب ووافقه تقرير مطول لصحيفه
الامارات اليوم قالوا انهم محاصرون بعدد
ضخم من الزيارات من قبل الشباب ببساطه
شباب كثيرون خائفون من اصابتهم بالمرض
هؤلاء الاطباء
توقعايد عدد المصابين بال
زعيمر من عمر الخمسه وستين عاما لكن لا
تقلق عزيزي الشاب هذه الاعراض التي لديك
تسمى الخرف الكاذب وفق الاطباء الحمد لله
لكن خلونا نكون صريحين وعادل ضروري انه
نكون صريحين لانه في شيء غلط الكل بيسال
سؤال واحد شو العلاقه ما بين كورونا وهذا
النسيان والجواب راح يكون على فكره معنا
بعد قليل خلونا بدايه نستمع لاراء
السعوديين حول هذا الموضوع موضوع النسيان
والله اكيد
من اول كان الواحد يستخدم اشياء في جسمها
في حركته في الان استخدم اللافتراضي كل
شيء يقضيه
بالتطبيق يقضي بالتليفون يقضيه فاختلف
الوضع يعني
يصير شويه من استخدامها التطبيقات السريعه
اولا يعني الناس الاولين يعني ما مروا على
ضغوطات ولا مشاكل ولا شيء اما هذا تحس
بالضغوطات اكبر ومسؤوليه اكبر وتحس انك
اصابك الزهايمر
او شاف وثائقي او شاف احد في العائله وصعب
زهايمر بيسم مبكر فساري اخاف انه ممكن هو
يصاب بالزهايمر والله انا اشوف ظروف
الحياه
المسؤوليات ايضا اللي تحاط به
يعني متوقع كل شخص وله ظرف ممكن هو اللي
يعدينا مصاب بالزعيم شوف ممكن انه العامل
النفسي تاثير يعني العامل النفسي تاثير
بنسبه كبيره
بالزهايمر
من عمان اختصاصيه الدماغ والاعصاب الدكتور
رائد نوفل ينضم الينا دكتور صبحك الله
بالخير
صباح
الخير اهلا وسهلا صباح يا دكتور يعني هل
هل هل السؤال الابرز لازم اسال بانه هل
اليوم لما اخذنا اللقاحات الكورونا هي
السبب بانه قاعد تخلينا ننسى باعتباري انا
لسه شاب
لا طبعا هي ما في ربط بين مطعوم الكورونا
والنسيان صارت شماعه طبعا لا ما في اي
علاقه بيناتهم
يعني على الاقل بشكل رسمي يعني ما في
دراسات تثبت بانه في علاقه ولكن هل يمكن
ان يكون في
علاقه وما بين تدهور الانشطه الدماغيه
للانسان
على الاقل من ناحيه نظريه هلا سواء من
نعم صحيح هلا مرض الكورونا او لقاحات مرض
الكورونا قد تسرع من بعض اعراض مرضى الخرف
يعني اللي بكون عنده خراف او بكون بدايه
الخرف وجود كورونا وجود الالتهابات او
وجود المطاعيم مع
اللي بصير منها انه قد تزيد اعراض الخرف
واعراضه جميعها طيب يعني دكتور اليوم
واحده من اعراض اللقاح حينما يعني اخذناه
كان على الاقل كنت في حاله غير طبيعيه انه
هذا مطعوم جديد دخل على الجسم ربما يعني
بعدم التركيز وهو ما دفع الناس الى تفكر
انه قد يكون بسبب هذه هذه اللقاحات هي ما
سببت اليوم الخرف الكاذب
هلا الخرف الكاذب او السوده ديمنشيان هي
طبعا شفناها كتير حالات هلا جديده صارت
تيجي على العيادات عندنا خصوصا تحت سن
الخمسين تحت سن الخمسين ما كنا نشوف بهذه
العيادات عنا مرضى بيجوا يحكوا لنا احنا
بلشنا ننسى احنا صرنا ما في تركيز الوظائف
اللي كنا نسويها صارت تاخذ معنا وقت اطول
صار الكل يذكرنا باخر سنتين ثلاثه شهدت
زياده ملحوظه عنا حتى في العيادات ولكن
يعني الخرف الخرف طبعا في في اسباب كثيره
هي طبعا لهاي الشغلات هلا الخرف الكاذب
عشان نحكي على الخرف الكاذب او السدود هي
اعراض تحاكي او تشابه الخرف الحقيقي ولكن
مع فروقات طبعا العوارض او الاهم الاسباب
للخرف الكاذب
الضغط النفسي الاكتئاب التوتر القلق
الوسواس الوسواس المرضي الوسواس النظافي
كل هاي الاعراض قد تؤدي الى اعراض الخرف
الكاذب من نقصان بالذاكره من اقسام
بالتركيز من عدم القدره على القيام
بالوظائف طيب دكتور بما انه يعني
كاذب وليس مرض الخرف اللي هو عباره عن
كابوس يعني عند الجميع خصوصا يعني عند
كبار السن خرف كاذب متى علينا ان نقلق
يعني اذا كنا بنعاني من زياده في نسيان
بكتير معلومات ايمتى علينا انه نقلق ونحس
انه لازم نروح نزور طبيب ولازم يكون في اي
تدخل طبي في هذا الموضوع
طبعا يعني اي مريض او اي انسان بيشتكي من
زياده بالنسيان للوضع انه اعاده السؤال
بشكل متكرر اثر على شغله اثر على
نفسيته صار عنده اعراض ثانيه غير يعني ما
كانت موجوده عنده لازم يراجع طبيب الاعصاب
هلا خلينا نحكي انه احنا كنسب نسب الخرا
فوق سن ال 65 يعني لما فوق الخمسه وستين
بتكون نسبتها خمسه بالميه بين العادي
لتحت من سن خمسين فمادون بتمثل عشرين
بالمئه الف وهي نسبه ضئيله جدا انه المريض
يصاب بالخرف الحقيقي واعراض الخرف في
الحقيقي يعني على اعراض الكاذب تحاكي جدا
وتشابه جدا القرف الكاذب او الخرف الحقيقي
دكتور نعم
ولا نساء اكثر
طبعا نساء ثلاث اضعاف اضعاف الرجال
لانه الحمد لله
طيب طبعا نتيجه الستريس اللي عليهم اكثر
الله يعني هي طبعا جينات بحته طبعا الامور
الله يعينهم الله يعينهم شكرا دكتور رائد
نوفل اختصاصي الدماغ والاعصاب من عمان
شكرا جزيلا لك ان شاء الله لنا طوله العمر
والصحه امين
[موسيقى]
يا رب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات